let's go next to our caller from the 907
area code who's calling today from 911
hello David yes that's you ah this is a
Justin from Brooklyn hey Justin what's
up um I'll try to make this brief
because I don't know how many of these
calls you get I had last week watched a
video from Kyle kolinsky about how
people who are deprogrammed from the
right should call in more to shows and
let people know that how you've helped
right to play a clip of one of my
callers saying that we a deprogrammed
yeah yeah yes so I felt I should do my
part and call in and say thank you okay
what what were what were your beliefs
that you were disabused of well if I
well one thing I have written down that
I feel really kind of angry not so much
angered me when I started moving out of
my comfort zone but I I was a big
listener of ben shapiro steven crowder
sargon of akkad
you know called benjamin yeah stefan
molyneux unfortunately so I mean I guess
you could kind of see the path I was
going down right and one thing that I
really that really kind of angered me
when I started listening to you Kyle Sam
is that they the right kind of creates
this caricature of the left of being
these like people with you know forgive
my language you know sticks up there but
you know not fun they're racist towards
and I know this is gonna I don't know if
this might sound weird to some but you
know the left is racist towards white
people and yeah they kind of don't draw
the line between say you and the pink
haired feminists that they love to Bank
on so much sure and I think it's a I
think it's a great thing because one
person who did also help me out a lot
was destiny interests and when I yeah
and one one debate that I had watched
that kind of brought me a little further
down the rabbit hole was one between
Sargon and
Spencer I didn't let me down too it's
interesting but that kind of led me down
a bit of a darker path until destiny
kind of jumped in and started debating
them now let me ask you this here's what
I want to understand and this is
something I didn't successfully ask
previous people who called in about when
they had these transitions what specific
issue did you believe in one way what
side of an issue were you on when you
were in that dark echo chamber and then
what is your position now like pick any
particular issue where your mind has
been changed okay so I guess what I
could pick one as being immigration okay
a lot of them like the statistics of
let's say you know one racial group
performs more crime than others okay
when in actuality like you know
immigrant groups don't commit as much
crime as Native American you know
American citizens so that was one thing
that I kind of had to reevaluate now
that's an interesting one because with a
lot of these issues what changes is
people's framework about the world
rather than they just are given new
facts and it's interesting that I mean
you know people like Daniel Kahneman
will often say you know we might think
that if you just throw facts at people
they'll change their minds but for most
people they're looking for facts that
support their pre-existing notion so
it's interesting that you mentioned that
one because it sounds like you're
suggesting on that issue of immigration
it's not necessarily that you're
morality or outlook changed it's that
when you believed immigrants
disproportionately commit more crime you
came to one conclusion about what policy
should be when you were given the
correct information that immigrants do
not commit more crime than native-born
citizens your position changed and
that's a very interesting because for a
lot of people they come up with their
opinion first and then find facts that
support it you know it wasn't very easy
to come to you know the conclusion that
you know I've been wrong for a while
sure no I don't think that's really
something anybody wants to do but I have
a bit of a cold but no yeah it's I don't
want to you know prop myself up either
but yeah you know I I like to take the
better better I'm sorry I'm a little
nervous but now provided with better
facts and information I have to change
my ideas because I would feel
disingenuous and dishonest if I didn't
because I know I'd be it's great that
you're saying that I mean that's just
not the way a lot of people work and and
it's not an ad hominem when I say that
it's just that we know that that's
that's how it works
Justin I appreciate the phone call I'm
gonna run because I've got a lot of
people holding but really great to hear
from you thank you for taking my call
all right Justin from Brooklyn
successfully deprogram great to hear
from him okay let's take a quick break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phones
momentarily don't hang up if you're
holding